- I love that you're a girl dad as well
'cause I saw this picture
and you're. I think you're
untangling your daughter's hair.
You like the, are you the tangle master?
- Look how,
look how terrified she looks there.
(laughing)
- So, so I mean, do
you, are you a girl dad,
do you love leaning into that?
- Oh, I lean into it with
all 280 pounds of my body.
I love that.
You know, and, and Kelly,
I have all daughters.
I have a 19 year old daughter,
a daughter, who's five,
a daughter who's getting
ready to turn three.
I was raised by women, strong women,
so I've, I've had my whole existence
has been surrounded by estrogen
with the exception of my dog,
but I love being a girl
dad and I love being a dad
and, and you know, I love,
I had my first daughter
I had when I was 29,
you know in your twenties as a dude,
you're still trying to figure things out
and when you get into
your thirties as a dude,
you're lucky if you can
continue to figure things out.
So I did a lot of growing
up with my first daughter.
So I'm really lucky and blessed
to have really little babies these days
as I'm a little older.
So I come to,
you know, the father daughter relationship
with a little bit more experience.
- Yeah, I think honestly too,
I mean, I'm, I was around 30, 31
when I, when I had 'em at first
and I think it's not even your age,
I think it's just the experience.
Like having a child is
a completely different,
I mean there's no
planning, there's no book.
Trust me, I read 'em.
Like, there's nothing
that can prepare you,
every kid is different.
You know, it's just a, it's a hard thing
the first time around, I think, you know,
the second one for me was so much easier.
So I think that, you know, any age,
it's just like that first
time, you're like, okay.
(laughing)
But you're--
- Yes, and you're terror,
you're terrified right?
You're terrified.
- Yes.
- It's like all parents are terrified
the very first child you have
you, you want to make sure
you're not doing anything wrong.
- Yeah.
- We're always checking to
see if they're breathing.
What's going on you're,
you don't get any sleep.
But it, it always, I always like to say
that you know, with children,
they are our great equalizer.
If you think you got it all figured out,
if you think you know how life is gonna go
they'll remind you that you don't
and if, and if you're
struggling to find some answers
and they're gonna be right there too
to help you find those answers.
- Yeah.
- That's what children do.
- I, I agree.
They keep you honest.
Well, here, I love this.
I was crying at this video.
I thought it was so funny
'cause my, this is, so my son, Remy,
he's four and here's your daughter though,
Tia in your pantry.
So what's going on here,
tell everybody what's up.
(laughing)
- I came around the corner
and she, there's boxes of
spaghetti on the floor.
And, and as you can see
she's pulling 'em out
and throwing them on the floor.
And I said, "Okay, so who, who did this?"
And she goes, "I don't know."
And I said, "Well, you have to look at me
when I'm talking to you."
And she looked up and
I said, "Who did this?"
I said "Did the spaghetti fairy come?"
And she's like, "Yes,
the paghetti fairy came
and threw all the pagetti on the floor."
And then right in front of me,
this is, this is the brilliance of kids,
right in front of me,
she drops all the spaghetti on the floor
and she goes, "Oh no, she did it again."
(laughing)
- That was my favorite
part of the video like,
and your laugh, your chuckle.
You're like, wait, what,
are you, are you serious?
- Laughing so hard,
the paghetti fairy did
it again it's just like.
- Oh my God, my son, he will,
he will lie right to my face.
And then I'll get, I get him and
I kind of know his, his like tells now,
but I'm like, ooh, you, you're tricky.
I'm worried about teenage years.